there's people dressed like you already
yeah
hundreds of costumes a tight turnaround
and a brilliantly collaborative process
just a small part of bringing the epic
eternals costumes hair and makeup to
life it's a lot of fun for you it was
when angelina jolie is in a film she
goes all out the actress was heavily
involved in the design and feel of her
character's look could we expect
anything less from the one and only
athena julie brought the costume makeup
and hair teams together so they could
bring her style out harmoniously
respecting the comic's representation
and including jolie's portrayal to bring
the most powerful character they could
to the screen
and that's when i found out i'd been
putting the pants on backwards
while kumail nanjiani looks as slick as
can be in his superhero costume the
actor awkwardly discovered a full three
weeks into filming that he'd had his
pants on backwards every day to be fair
it wasn't like he was throwing on
civilian clothing it's my first time
being a superhero it's your first
superhero movie the eternal suits came
with many parts which could get kind of
confusing to put on the right way and
with so many people there to help we can
just imagine how chaotic dressing would
be the whole process took a fair amount
of time and the long hours on set are
already exhausting as it is so really it
could happen to anybody now while the
discovery he was misdressing himself for
weeks at work was no doubt awkward this
new information was tough for the actor
to face for quite a different reason
nanjani is a very talented actor in fact
he even taught himself a new skill on
the set of eternals by fluke since
nanjiani's pants were on backwards it
seemed as though going to the washroom
would cause quite a ruckus especially
since so many people had to help him get
into it so he opted to be a team player
and figure out how to not need the
bathroom for long periods of time if i
was wearing it all day i would like not
have water not have coffee like be
careful right fortunately his co-star
brian tyree henry let him in on a
helpful secret and he said there's a
zipper
this was the moment he figured out those
pants were on the wrong way anyone else
get totally caught in the brilliant
visuals of the bollywood magic happening
in eternals this scene was a dream come
true for the designer sarancoli who
literally tripped while on the phone
when discovering he'd gotten the gig on
this epic marvel movie excited to share
his bollywood style and represent south
asians saron was responsible for
designing the costumes for all 52
dancers we see in the scene and he
helped out with kumails as well
[Music]
never thought she'd be playing a
superhero and even almost completely
passed on eternals because she was
worried they'd want her to play
someone's grandmother
while she was excited by the whole
experience she didn't feel too eager to
try on her superhero outfit i'm
claustrophobic i was terrified of the
costume luckily once she actually had it
on any fear of claustrophobia or
overwhelm melted away i found myself
profoundly moved and it shows through
her performance costume designer sami
sheldon differ had it right when she
said hayek looked like the ceo of the
universe in her costume when some eager
fans caught a peek of what was going on
behind the scenes of eternals a rumor
went around that jolie had gone blonde
for the movie and she did except there
was no hair dye in sight jolie's wig had
an impressive team behind it gretchen
evans made the base another hair stylist
blaine dowling was responsible for
getting the color just right and academy
award winner adruthalee made it camera
perfect styling on point but like you're
like oh you know it's a it's quite hard
to move in barry kilgan might have
wished his costume actually was cgi
since the actor constantly felt
overwhelmed by his outfits and all three
layers they came with i complained every
day about it coming back to set after
the holidays wasn't so great either
since the already constricting costumes
felt quite a bit more snug despite any
discomfort the actor felt he couldn't
help but admire just how epic these
costumes looked in the end
i did love my costume and the color of
it and everything
but considering some of the warm
climates filming did take place we can't
totally blame him for all the
complaining on set
seeing yourself as a superhero for the
first time no doubt brings all the feels
it's always overwhelming you put these
things on for the first time just the
experience of doing fittings was very
emotional for brian tyree henry as he
wasn't totally convinced he could be
made to look like a superhero but sure
enough the costume department showed him
the hero he could be it's really great
to show that anybody can be a hero
trying on his finished costume and
looking in the mirror left the actor in
tears could we love this film and cast
anymore
one of the best parts of building the
eternals world was how collaborative the
process was between the performers and
the costume department
i mean what was great about this is we
had such a wonderful improvement sammy
sheldon differ who designed the costumes
for eternals became a cast favorite
helping them find themselves in these
characters and all while ensuring the
actors were comfortable enough to
perform i go in and i'm like oh this the
other costume is you know cutting me off
there in the ribs then you know they
they would just tweak and tweak and
tweak typically the makeup trailer is
limited to just a handful of performers
at a time if not just one depending on
the makeup needs but when doing eternals
the makeup truck was more like a makeup
party bus the major makeup truck had 10
seats in it so all the leads could get
prepped together all of the actors had
their own makeup artist could we expect
anything less from a marvel movie while
plenty of time was spent joking around
and catching up with each other when
crunch time came along they got to
rehearse their dialogue for huge scenes
all together while prepping needless to
say by the end of filming this marvel
family was extremely close not only were
they costuming marvel superheroes these
performers had extensive wardrobes
anyone who's around through thousands of
years would need a multitude of clothing
staples right rather than just choosing
costumes based on what might look good
the civilian outfits for present day
continued to represent the core of their
characters making sure there was a
common tie between each of their
different outfits the colors of all
their different costumes having a
similar vibe is no coincidence after
about four months of designing costumes
the team quickly began building some of
the hundreds of outfits needed in the
summer so they could film in october the
tweaking unsurprisingly continued well
into december though they had their work
cut out for them with each superhero
suit taking at least a full two weeks to
build and that isn't even considering
the nine copies that were needed for the
stunt performers picture doubles and
just backups the designs of these
costumes were exquisite but bringing all
the magic captured on a 2d surface to
the camera was a major feat
140 workers were on the case custom
making suits that were broken down into
anywhere from 20 to over 200 separate
pieces zippers snaps velcro whatever
could get the job done and allow the
actor to move well feel like there were
similarities between certain characters
looks within the eternals half of them
were put into team thinkers while the
other half were team fighters the
thinkers had more of a flowing look to
their outfits while the fighters well
their gear had to enable them to do what
they do best in every case they hit the
right marks these costumes are brilliant
but complicated i just arrived at the
red carpet and i started seeing
all these people dressed as us she was
emotional seeing herself in her ajax
costume for the first time but what
really got salma hayek in the feels was
seeing so many people dressed up as
their characters at the premiere i
wanted to cry one family in particular
really moved the actress the father then
the mother was dressed they were latinos
as ajax and the three little daughters
also like ajax we can't blame kumail for
having trouble with his superhero suit
hopefully he can help future marvel
actors figure out how to be able to go
to the washroom in their costumes